joining us on the phone from London
right now is Toby Hamnett he is legal
advisor for the British cave Rescue
Council and he's been in touch with
rescue divers on the scene in Thailand
Toby good morning to you good morning
yeah what's the most important thing for
the divers right now and do you expect
others will be rescued today the rescue
is going to be always subject to a
moving assessment to ensure that
whatever happens it's the safest
possible environment not only for the
children but also for the divers QT no
all volunteers from around the world
Toby the distance between the mouth of
the cave and where the boys are trapped
is over two and a half miles describe
how perilous that situation is in any
cave environment it can become very
difficult but in a cave environment such
as this which is now flooded to the roof
in large parts of that with water the
visibility is poor not ended because
Oxley because in the dark but also at
the storm waters of the monsoon who
would have churned up lots of mud on the
way and the cave itself had
constrictions on those which do cause
some difficulties Toby this is a
challenge even for the most experienced
divers explain to us what it must be
like to try to teach a young boy some of
whom don't even know how to swim how to
go through this perilous journey
Funston cutting edge of this rescue are
very sure of themselves
they're able to project their capability
and their confidence very clearly I know
to ensure this trust between the rescue
team and the divers in Falls
all right Toby Hammond it the world is
watching everyone's watching hoping and
praying at the same time it's so far so
good thank you very much for joining us
this morning
Beckham's thank you very much and some
of the parents have sent letters to
their kids inside one says no that
mommy's waiting for you in front of the
cave I miss you please don't feel bad
another mom says dad mom are waiting to
arrange a birthday party please get out
soon and stay healthy mommy knows you
can do it so imagine what that's like
but the best letter I think is going to
the coach from all the parents please
don't blame yourself for this
we want you to rest a short every parent
is not upset and angry we
you and everybody understands and
supports you that must mean a lot to him
in the serpent he apologized you know
you read those letters and you imagine a
small boy being underwater and you look
at the cave and the way it goes you get
claustrophobic just reading about it how
they can have the patience and restraint
to make it out I think one story is
gonna be that Coach Gale because he
apparently had studied at a Buddhist
monastery and you mentioned this he's
been talking about meditations currently
he's a very calm guy God well we all
need a little meditation until this is
take me